was actually it was two weeks ago today
and uh i was just arriving at the at the
uh hospital
um i'd
not been well all over the weekend and
i'd been resting up
thinking it was my usual heart condition
and
on monday morning things weren't
settling down so i
decided i'd contact my gp
and they said look
you need to pay 999
so i did that
and unfortunately because the ambulance
has all been being held up
at the hospital um it took
several hours for an ambulance to arrive
and then um
and then
when we got there
um
there were 33 ambulances waiting outside
and
it was it was just a horrendous
situation
um
i they i did get taken in relatively
quickly the ambulance crew made sure
because i had chest pain that i was
taken in
and i was given an ecg
and i was given blood tests
and then i was sent back out to the
ambulance to wait
um
my troponin test was negative which
proved that i hadn't had a heart attack
which was very reassuring
um but
you know i do have a chronic heart
condition so um
we're continuing to wait in in the
ambulance the ambulance crew were
getting ready for me to spend the night
in the ambulance people have been
spending the 24 hours plus
in their ambulances
and
then they came out and said that my
covered test was positive
and
the consultant had said that my heart
problems were because of clovid
so at 10 o'clock that evening they
discharged me home
and on sorry to interrupt you but then
you you experienced the pains again and
then you took the decision to drive
i mean 300 miles to a london hospital
just explain
why you too honestly took that decision
to be honest the pain was there all the
time
and um
it wasn't until the um
the wednesday afternoon after spending
uh time trying to contact other
hospitals that um in the wednesday
evening we decided that we had no option
but uh traveling to london because
allison wasn't getting any better um and
we knew that going back to trilisk was
going to be pretty pointless and uh so
we decided that the only way forward is
to get in the car and drive up to
charing cross
ross what did you do what did you think
sorry to attract what did you think
about a journey
for what 300 miles to charing cross
hospital in west london i mean where
when when alison was experiencing these
chest pains
you know somebody said it's a calculated
risk um
but to not to have gone would have been
a bigger risk and to have jumped in the
car and
i knew that for five hours um she was in
some danger but um i thought if we
hadn't gone during even greater danger
so it wasn't a difficult decision to
make again